à
bonjour ça va toujours chercher toujours
chargé ça fait un petit bout me va nous
verrez vous allez découvrir et se
dégradent nos poules on attendait donc
pour lui ont dit un oui certainement
vous avez y en a des petits mots
jurassien pas seulement les polinois
lorsqu'ils ont un voeu à formuler pays
la porte et veut des zones à risques
mais c'est aussi une marque de leur
insertion dans la vie sociale la comédie
je pense à l'occasion du marché qui
vendent il ya punis dans des sens à la
vie dans les dix ans et joe biden et au
clarissa sachant aussi que sait-on
participation à cet ordre
étant un mendiant donc une soeur aînée
de ce congé
ce n'est pas ce qui s'est passé je sais
reconnaître qu'ils ont cru nous sonnera
la cloche pour que les gens savent elles
voulaient peut-être des jeunes ados pour
que les gens savent que vous manquez
jamais eu besoin ce n'est pas pour nous
ça nous fait plaisir mais on a autant de
joie à donner qu'à recevoir
on dit ça mais c'est vrai aussi mais à
tout à fait c'est ce que je dis oui
beaucoup et on vient au monastère et
quand on repart et bien il ya quelque
chose qui fait que l'on est mieux quand
on s'en va que comme martin ça c'est sûr
c'est vrai que dans un monde où on juge
les gens et la société sur l'efficacité
et la rentabilité et matérielles elle
apporte un certain contraste et il me
semble mois qu'elle pose question
dupuis
oh
adieu plaisent pollini telle est la
devise de la petite ville fortifiée du
jura qui séduisit sainte-colette l'art
et novatrice de l'ordre des clarisses en
1415 à la demande de marguerite de
bavière jean-sans-peur donna à sainte
colette son arsenal pour y bâtir un
monastère elle même il séjourne à une
dizaine d'années ces ossements furent
amenés à poligny en 1783 chez les
clarisses comme chez les carmélites
l'oraison marque le début de la journée
monastique à la belle saison
les soeurs de pollini se dispersent à
l'aube dans les superbes jardins en
terrasse pour y pratiquer leurs prières
silencieuses quotidienne
puis vient le temps de la lectio divina
une lecture approfondie de la gibbs
notre corps est constitué de plusieurs
espaces et chaque tout ce qui constitue
notre être humain doit être pris
s'approfondit enfin au fur et à mesure
de mon expérience qui continue parce que
qui ne sera jamais fini
mais je m'aperçois que tout ce qui nous
est donné pour entrer dans cette
expérience spirituelle ou au coeur du
monde parce que nous restons lui même
profondément humaine de plus en plus
même d'ailleurs à mesure que nous
entrons de plus en plus dans cette
expérience spirituelle
le seigneur veut nous emmener vers la
liberté des enfants de dieu soeur
élisabeth madeleine et malgache
elle est en france depuis quatre ans sa
venue illustre bien le mouvement actuel
qui voit beaucoup de moins des pays du
sud venir suppléer leurs frères et
soeurs occidentaux ceux ci souffrent du
vieillissement général de leur
population et d'un manque cruel de vos
questions nouvelles toutes les vocations
de madagascar actuellement ça vient de
familles pauvres très pauvres et donc le
monastère où les communautés participe
beaucoup à la formation pour les jeunes
qu'ils entrent jeu depuis dix ans
presque tout et la maison des formations
sont pleines presque tout est dans tout
madagascar c'est aussi les hauts
plateaux et presque toutes les maisons
sont pleins alors qu'ici je pense que le
défi est différente très très différents
je ne sais pas c'est toujours mais pour
moi je pense qu'ici c'est trop
matérialiser donc il ya trop de choses
et qu'on est plus attirée dans le
matériel est peut-être laissé mon
jugement qu'il faut mais quand on est
trop
lemattre elle en oublie peut-être
l'essentiel
à
il
oui
je suis d'une famille ils sont
efflanqués puisque j'ai dépensé ramaré
j'avais toute la misère humaine dans ma
famille sont pas bio parce que dans ma
famille aussi
la prostitution donc je suis là pour
porter un peu tous ces gens aujourd'hui
ces drames et spécialement les enfants
moi j'aurais pu s'épancher
j'en suis vraiment de toutes les données
mais j'ai choisi justement la vengeance
de l'amour comme se dit dans les veines
je vis et je me vengerai de bon ses bons
jours
je prie beaucoup aussi pour elle c'est
tous ces gens qui sont pédophiles coeur
de beaucoup c'est terrible quand on a vu
que la mère de deux jeunes gens
trouvaient ça semble oui l'avait renier
de manger télévision où justement à moi
quand j'entends des serres génie balle
mois il sera mon fils dans la prière et
vraiment je prie pour cette moto méchant
je commence parce qu'il arrêtait la
classe qui la paye la cervelle pour
rejoindre voleur s il a fait ce qu'il
veut laisser quelque part
les dix sept soeurs de sainte claire de
poligny manges tu en silence comme dans
la plupart des monastères mais parfois
au lieu de la lecture traditionnelle
elle écoute en déjeunant le journal de
rcf la radio catholique du côté
palestinien reste à faire accepter ses
promesses par les deux peuples
un père le poker c'est aujourd'hui son
100ème voyage quel genre de joueur à
tout à l'heure pour la croatie vouloir
rester cinq jours la voyage hautement
symbolique est très attendu dans le pays
entrant la surpopulation carcérale
encore atteindre
mais le nombre record de détenus dans
les prisons alarme les syndicats de
surveillants étaient aussi
éducation dès nos débuts la lutte contre
la pauvreté en cause nationale voilà ce
premier de la finance la fédération
nationale des associations d'accueil et
de réinsertion sociale sur l'âge et la
douleur physique lors des
hospitalisations mais aussi les douleurs
psychologiques et sociales ouverture est
vendu à l'issue du congrès sur les soins
palliatifs
voir ça s'est passé en fait vous avez
comment vous avez connu ce monastère
j'étais je suis à mettre 50 je suis ici
vous étiez les cas récents et logique
lorsque c'est fermé parce que tu n'as
pas de recrutement connaîtront la plus
de jeunes pouvaient pas cool tu l'aimés
quoi ici vous voudrez bien je me posais
des questions
certains parents estiment enfin est ce
que je suis vraiment ma place
c'est ça le doute et je crois je suis
vraiment ma classe finalement il serait
temps de penser à 80
non mais c'est sûr biche sur ton mois -
d la crise des quarante ans la 45e
c'est sûr qu'à ce moment là aussi on se
pose des questions c'est normal
oui je suis pas très très bonne heure
mais 28 ans quand je compterai mais
c'est certain que le plus gros
sacrifices pour moi tout au moins
c'était me dire jamais je serai maman ça
c'est dur surtout quand on est forcément
plus ou moins dix était enfant dans la
famille des petites nièces qui sont
vraiment des trésors quoi alors je dis
jamais jamais comme ça embête pas dire
si j'ai su qu'ils ont maculées je suis
devenu petit j'étais petit mais chut
tellement petit maintenant
oh
j'ai vécu en afrique puisqu'à jusqu'à ce
que je passe mon bac j'ai vraiment été
confronté à la misère extrême
particulier à la mort des enfants
j'ai un père qui travaille pour la
communauté européenne et donc parfois il
est d'aider des projets soutenus par des
religieux il nous disait ben oui j'ai bu
un frère franciscain pleurer dans mon
bureau un enfant d hydrater est mort
dans ses bras
je me suis dit hé bien où je passe ma
vie à poser des bombes dans le monde
pour dire que le monde est vraiment
pourri tellement pourri qu'un enfant
peut mourir
déshydraté dans les bras d'un frère
franciscain où je rentrerai dans un
monastère pour que ma vie ma vie
appartiennent à tous parce que la tempe
ailleurs en tout cas j'ai complique
m'effraie c'est vraiment elles sont
vraiment du bien parce que c'est la
période où on n'a pas beaucoup de fruits
quand j'ai annoncé à mes parents que
j'avais décidé de répondre à cet appel
et d'entrer au monastère
papa m'a dit si tu rentres monastère tu
ne me reverras plus parce que vie
monastique ça voulait dire
elle reviendra plus à la maison on
partagera plus qu'on a partagé ensemble
pour les moments importants à vivre en
famille on sera pas ensemble donc tout
ça c'était c'était dur pour eux et la
réaction de papa c'était cette réaction
sur cette souffrance qui sentait la et
puis une certaine peur aussi de se dire
est ce que ça va pas être trop dur pour
elle est ce qu'elle n'a pas mis la barre
trop est ce que vraiment est ce que
vraiment dieu l'appelle là est-ce que
c'est pas monter la tête
est-ce qu'elle avait pas un idéal
d'absolu qui a fait que allez je
m'embarque que dans une vie complètement
impossible vu de l'extérieur pour
contenter un peu mon ego relevant le
défi
et puis la peur de se dire aussi ce
qu'elles devraient s est ce qu'elle sera
vraiment heureuse vie sexuelle c'est en
grand moff j'avais eu mes expériences et
les ma vie affective
c'est très proche du deuil de la
maternité effectivement mon corps il est
fait pour les relations sexuelles et
j'ai aussi un renoncement à vivre alors
il ya des moments ça se passe très bien
et c'est très facile à vivre
et puis il ya des moments c'est plus
rude où je sens vraiment le manque la
frustration
je pense qu'il ya des sus des
frustrations assumer alors paisiblement
ou pas paisiblement suivant les moments
mais assumé
celle ci
jo
les clarisses ont une heure de
récréation en début d'après midi
c'est un moment de détente et de
défoulement particulièrement essentiel
pour les plus jeunes d'entre elles
attention de l'écran n'est pas ma tête
est en place il serait surtout ce jeudi
ce sera loin des records pour la pêche
cette année marquant le 700e
anniversaire de la naissance de sainte
claire les soeurs accueille chaque
mercredi du mois de juin 250 enfants du
diocèse
ces rencontres illustre bien leur
excellente insertion dans la vie locale
et
ordu
il est pour demain
les goûts
voulait
oh
et
nous allons entrer dans votre réfectoire
le bouddha de plus ces nombreuses années
en fait nous vivons ensemble une vie de
famille on est des soeurs ensemble et
pourtant bien pas du même endroit sur
mario land qui est philippines
vous avez vu aussi je pense inquiets la
sciatique
elle a fait 22 heures d'avion pour venir
ici on est vraiment différente
et pourtant mes soeurs vous avez vu et
jésus est récente et plus grand rapport
le coût de l'ensemble ça veut dire que
je suis elle hésite et il vit en nous et
il est payé son local vous avez compris
quelque chose ça passe pour entrer dans
le
et lens et porta prix
tous
cheveux
le coeur bien changer ça
oh
j'ai pas ce que tu leur as fait mme
massé se disant que ça n'a pas du tout
de moi c'est pas du tout nombreuses à
venir de oui c'est vraiment l'expérience
qu'ils font eux mêmes mais c'est ce que
j'ai envie de les introduire un peu mais
c'est tout mais bkc qui m'ont dit si
vous aviez vu deux visages d'enfants qui
était complètement pris par son amant et
leur silence voir dans la présence de
dieu en eux mêmes
maintenant avec tout le cheminement que
j'ai eus je me suis aperçu que l'appel
du jésus est venu se greffer sur une
blessure d'enfants et oui c'est pour moi
c'est merveilleux de prendre conscience
de cela et à partir de ce moment il ne
m'a jamais lâché et c'est parce qu'il
était là m'accompagnant dans la vie avec
tous les moments douloureux que j'ai pu
traverser parce que j'ai une vie très
douloureuse et il était là est bon je
vivais à peu cette cette amitié secrète
et je pense que déjà la prière et r mais
c'est petit à petit de cette amitié que
je vis fait à l'intérieur de moi
en 1415 sainte-colette récupère des
entrepôts d'armes à poligny et les
transforment en monastère dédiée à
sainte claire ça ne collait pas eu
l'intuition qu'il y avait une source
dans le monastère
donc elle est venue ici elle a fait
appeler des ouvriers et elle leur a
demandé de creuser pour trouver la
source qui se trouvaient là et les gens
qui connaissaient bien le qui
connaissait bien le coin lui ont dit
mais c'est même pas la peine qu'on
commence à élever la pioche parce que on
sait très bien qu'il ya pas de source
ici est alors sur l'insistance de
collecte ils ont sont quand même mis à
creuser
mais on a découvert très peu de
profondeur d'ailleurs trois sources qui
qui qui se rejoignent justement mpuila
donc été donc été construits et les
soeurs n'ont pu été obligé de sortir du
monastère pour aller chercher
alors non seulement il y avait il y
avait la grille mais lorsque les soeurs
s'approchait de la grid lbc le voile
jusqu'en bas du visage pour qu'on ne
voit jamais le visage les médecins
venaient des dentistes des chez nous
tout se déranger c'est une autre quand
elle s'était voilà c'était encore un peu
plus la brutalité du moyen-âge
après le concile
la communauté a fait le choix de
descendre la chapelle avec les gens qui
méprisent est avec nous les pauvres
dames comme les nomades même
sainte-claire son fils de saint françois
d'assise
chaque monastère est régi par une
abaisse élus pour trois ans et
rééligible
on compte aujourd'hui en france 750
clarisse d'environ 45 monastère depuis
14 115 des clarisses de pollini ne
durent quitter qu'une seule fois leur
abbaye au moment de la révolution
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
elles ne furent pas inquiété il se
raconte qu'une fois en passant le long
d'un mur qui longe la rue elle avait
entendu dire un allemand parlé avec un
parler en français à une personne
française
il dure de toute façon ici on y viendra
passer des folles donc elles ont été
tranquilles
jusqu en 1945-46 j'ai pas exactement les
soeurs de la communauté étaient enterrés
ici
et puis une fois que cimetière était
plein
eh bien on s'est déplacé en ville les
soeurs de polynies sont toujours restés
fidèles à leur vocation d' ordres
mendiants
quand vatican ii demande au moins de
gagner leur pain elle se lance dans
plusieurs ateliers tels que la
fabrication de ce type ou la confection
d'ornement mais cela ne représente
jamais qu'une petite partie de leurs
revenus
l'essentiel étant toujours constitué de
dons ou des retraites des anciennes un
jour il y avait un ancien qui marchait
sur la messe en plein désert
donc elle pas d'eau potable il marchait
sur le bord de la mer avec un de ses
disciples un jeune disciple et ses
disciples au bout de plusieurs heures à
rennes son ancien me dit ah bah j'ai
soif
l'ancien fait le signe de croix sur la
mer et puis lui dit bois c'est potable
et le jeune ben ward et et puis l'ancien
continue de marcher
et puis le disciple avec ça mais l'autre
vous savez ces saucisses et sous leur
manteau il est en train de vouloir faire
une autre pour garder nos potable et
l'ancien se retourne il est dit mais
qu'est ce que tu fais est le disciple
utile et abat on a encore plusieurs
heures de marche et l'ancien lui répond
du est ici du est ailleurs en tout cas
c'est bien dommage que tous nos toits ne
soit pas le faire rester sans suite
ça fait là aussi on fait un petit peu
d'intervalle
et puis tu as l'autre là ça commençait
très crue